the world at the end of the decade will
have eight billion people they'll be
carrying twenty billion mobile devices
and we want to know how we can keep up
with that huge amount of information and
rather than let someone else think of
the new thing with that what would be
like if we were to change the world
[Music]
Moore's law is actually not a physical
law it's an observation
we take devices in every generation we
try and make them half the size that
they were before the observation made by
Gordon Moore was that about every 18 to
24 months the number of transistors you
could fit into a given piece of silicon
semiconductor was going to double the
industry has chased this as that
benchmark for continuous improvement and
that's gonna stop things are gonna start
to slow down on that Moore's law of
improvement because things are just
getting too small to get any smaller so
we find ourselves running out of
computation technology that has lifted
our productivity as an economy from at
least 50 years what if everything
changed all at once
I am overseeing a project we call the
Machine the machine will be far more
powerful than today's computers and
consume far less energy it will allow us
to extract insights from enormous
datasets in real time
we'll actually have a tiny laser source
and they'll be shooting photons between
each other
creating much greater capacity for
information transmission and a much much
lower power my name is Kirk Persinger
and I'm a fellow here at Hewlett Packard
Laboratories and I get to dream up crazy
things and say you know what we're gonna
do this we want to show that we have a
really good shot at surpassing the
current level of performance
[Music]